We are part of nature,
and just as we take care of ourselves
we must take care of nature.
To me, nature is magical.
There is nothing like it.
Travelling and seeing new places
really opens your mind.
I chose to come and do this Erasmus
here in Sicily.
It's one of the best places to work
in the field of environmental control
and education.
The organisation where I have spent my
training period has a principal mission:
the protection, control and monitoring
of the land and sea environments.
My experiences here
have made me stronger,
able to be more independent,
more flexible,
to work harder than before.
When we go back to our country,
companies will look for people
who have acquired these kinds of skills,
this flexibility.
Without the Erasmus programme
I wouldn't have been able to come here.
No one is going to sort it out for me:
if I don't fight for myself,
I won't have the future I want.
It has made me fight for my own dreams!